This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. There's a video on YouTube you might have seen. It has nearly 200 million views. In this video, a pair of twin brothers are standing in a kitchen, having a little chat. These twin brothers, a diaper clad, babies. A diaper clad. Babies. Now, if this video featured 10-year-old twins or adult twins, I guarantee you it wouldn't have gone viral.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。YouTube上有一个视频，你可能看过。它的播放量接近两亿次。在这个视频里，一对双胞胎兄弟正站在厨房里，聊着天。这对双胞胎兄弟，还穿着尿布，是婴儿。穿着尿布的婴儿。现在，如果这个视频的主角是十岁的双胞胎或者成年的双胞胎，我向你保证它绝对不会火遍全网。
What makes this video special is that we have no clue what these babies are saying. To us non babies, it sounds like Goblety Goook. Cute, mysterious, gobbledygook. Here at Hidden Brain, we love trying to understand the puzzles and contradictions of human behavior. But we spend most of our time talking about the older members of the human race. Today, we focus on the younger set. The much younger set. I find babies are so impressive. We can't really ask them what they're thinking. We have to come up with clever ways of figuring out what's going on in their little brains.
这个视频之所以特别，是因为我们根本听不懂这些婴儿在说些什么。对于我们这些非婴儿的人来说，听起来就像是一堆胡话。可爱、神秘的胡言乱语。在《隐藏的大脑》，我们喜欢试着去理解人类行为中的谜题和矛盾。但我们大部分时间都在讨论人类中比较年长的成员。今天，我们把镜头对准年龄较小的一群人。年纪小得多的一群人。我发现婴儿太让人惊叹了。我们无法真正问他们在想什么。我们必须想出巧妙的方法，去弄清楚他们的小脑袋瓜里究竟在想些什么。
Later in the show, we'll hear from a researcher who says parents are often misguided when they try to steer their children's lives. If you just do the right things, get the right skills, read the right box, you're going to be able to shape your child into a particular kind of adult. But first, we'll start with a language of babies, even babies who don't speak words. Hi, I'm Laura Sreli. When Laura was in college, she spent her summer vacations back home in Sabri, Ontario, and she worked at the magical nook, a daycare center. It was a large center that had different age groups, so
在节目的后半部分，我们将听到一位研究人员的观点，她说父母在试图引导孩子的生活时往往走入了误区。如果你只是做了对的事，掌握了正确的技能，读了正确的书，你就能把你的孩子塑造成为某种特定类型的成年人。但首先，我们要从婴儿的语言讲起，甚至是那些还不会说话的婴儿。你好，我是劳拉·斯雷利。劳拉上大学时，暑假都会回到安大略省萨德伯里的家中，她在一家名为“神奇角落”的托儿所工作。这是一个很大的托儿所，有不同的年龄段，所以
there was a baby room and a toddler room, preschooler, school-aged children, but my favorite room was the toddler room for sure. Laura's job was to help the teachers at the center engage with the kids and enforce the rules. Music was an essential tool. We would sing wheels on the bus. All the bus going round the bus. Old McDonald.
有婴儿室、学步儿室、学前班、学龄儿童，但我最喜欢的绝对是学步儿室。劳拉的工作是帮助托儿所的老师与孩子们互动并执行规则。音乐是一个必不可少的工具。我们会唱《车轮在公交车上转》。公交车转呀转。老麦克唐纳。
Old McDonald's had a farm. E-I.E. If we didn't sing the cleanup song, the preschoolers, then I don't think anything would have ever gotten cleaned up. We'd clean up everybody everywhere. But as soon as we started, it seemed to be the trick to convince them that, yes, they were willing to put their toys away.
老麦克唐纳有个农场，咿呀咿呀呦。如果我们不唱收拾玩具歌，那些学前班的孩子们，我想可能永远都不会把东西收拾干净。我们到处帮大家收拾。但只要我们一唱起这首歌，这似乎就成了诀窍，能让他们相信，是的，他们愿意把玩具收好。
We'd clean up everybody. Lorda regularly found herself in awe of the toddlers. One little kid who I had a good connection with, she grabbed my hand and brought me over to the little slide. And she really wanted to go down the slide, you could tell. So I helped her up the little stairs and I caught her at the bottom of the slide. And all the rest of the toddlers in this playground just looked over and saw her and looked at each other and then ran over to the side and formed a cute little line up waiting her
我们帮大家收拾。劳拉经常对学步儿们惊叹不已。有个和我关系很好的小孩子，她拉着我的手，把我带到小滑梯旁。你能看出来，她是真的很想滑滑梯。所以我帮她爬上小楼梯，并在滑梯底部接住了她。而这个游乐场里的所有其他学步儿看到这一幕后，都看了看彼此，然后跑过来排成了一条可爱的小队伍，等着我
turn for me to help them down. Laura's days at the magical nook are over. She's now a professor at the University of Toronto's Carbure and her work focuses on early childhood development. With years of knowledge now under her belt, she looks back on that moment at the slide and sees it as a form of communication. In order for kids to look around and see what their peers are doing and to understand the goals that are embedded in those activities and to then realize that they need to follow the social construct of lining up. It seems like a super simple thing, but there's a lot of understanding about themselves,
帮他们滑下去。劳拉在“神奇角落”的日子已经结束了。她现在是多伦多大学卡尔堡分校的一名教授，她的研究重点是幼儿发展。如今带着多年的专业知识，她回想起滑梯旁的那个时刻，并将其视为一种交流形式。为了让孩子们四处张望并观察同龄人的行为，去理解这些活动中包含的目标，然后意识到他们需要遵循排队的社会规则。这看起来是一件超级简单的事情，但其中包含着对自我的大量认知，
about other people, about goals and activities that they need to really completely understand in order for that to happen. Laura says actions like standing in line for the slide can be categorized as pro-social behaviors. They're actions we take to help others and to benefit the group. She decided to study what she'd seen on the playground more systematically. She invited a bunch of parents to bring their toddlers into the lab.
对其他人、对他们为了让这一切发生而需要彻底理解的目标和活动的认知。劳拉说，排队等滑梯这样的行为可以归类为亲社会行为。这是我们采取的旨在帮助他人和造福群体的行动。她决定更系统地研究她在游乐场里看到的情景。她邀请了一群父母把他们的学步儿带到实验室里。
We were specifically testing 14 month old babies, so they're walking, they're not quite talking. These 14 month olds said bye bye to mommy and daddy, and then was strapped into front facing baby carriers worn by assistance in the study. The researchers turned on some music. And the person carrying the baby began to bounce. It was like... So we would bounce them down on one beat enough on the other, down and up sort of thing. So if you're this baby, you're strapped onto someone's chest, you can't see their face. Instead, you're looking in front of you at another assistant. The person facing the baby would either move in synchrony with how they were being
我们专门测试的是14个月大的婴儿，所以他们会走路，但还不太会说话。这群14个月大的宝宝跟爸爸妈妈说拜拜，然后被固定在研究助理胸前佩戴的前置婴儿背带里。研究人员打开了一些音乐。背着婴儿的人开始上下晃动。就像这样……所以我们会顺着一个节拍往下沉，再顺着另一个节拍往上抬，差不多就是上下晃动那种。所以如果你是这个宝宝，你被绑在某个人的胸前，你看不到他们的脸。相反，你正看着正前方的另一个助理。面对婴儿的那个人要么会随着
bounced, so they were bouncing together, or they would move either too quickly or too slowly so that their movements weren't aligned with what the baby was experiencing. After about two and a half minutes, the bouncing stopped and the baby was removed from the carrier. And then this person who had faced them and moved either in or out of sync with them would perform some little simple social games with them. So she would do things like job pictures with markers or throw paper balls in a bucket. Every now and then, the assistant who had faced the baby would drop a marker or paper ball
被晃动的节奏同步移动，也就是说他们一起晃动，要么就会动得太快或太慢，以至于他们的动作与婴儿所经历的节奏不一致。大约两 and a half 分钟后，晃动停止了，婴儿被从背带里抱了出来。然后，这个面对过他们、动作与他们同步或不同步的人，会和他们玩一些简单的小社交游戏。比如用记号笔画画，或者把纸球扔进桶里。时不时地，面对婴儿的那位助理会掉落一支记号笔或一个纸球，
and then pretend like the object was out of reach. She would reach pathetically for them for about 30 seconds and we look to see what the babies did in this really weird situation where this person they just met needs help, but isn't really asking for help and doesn't really seem to be able to achieve their goal on their own. Laura measured how many babies would pick up and hand back the objects. And looked at whether the babies who we bounced in sync with helped at a different rate than the babies we bounced out of sync with.
然后假装这个物体够不着了。她会可怜兮兮地伸手去够大约 30 秒钟，而我们则观察婴儿在这个非常奇怪的情况下会有什么反应——这个他们刚认识的人需要帮助，但并没有真正开口求助，而且看起来凭自己的力量无法达到目标。劳拉统计了有多少婴儿会捡起并将物品递还回去。并观察了那些与我们同步晃动的婴儿，其帮助的比例是否与那些不同步晃动的婴儿有所不同。
She found that babies who felt that they were bouncing in sync with a dance partner were more likely to help that partner pick up an object when it was out of reach. It was remarkable. So they would help on over half of the trials if we moved in sync with them. Whereas if we moved out of sync with them they would help on less than a half of the trials if we moved in sync with them. Whereas if we moved out of sync with them, they would help on less than a third of the trials. You've likely experienced the same drive if you've ever moved in sync with someone else. Maybe on a sports team in school or in marching band. Or maybe like Laura as a dancer. The song was a soundtrack of Laura's last recycle in high school,
她发现，那些觉得自己与舞伴同步晃动的婴儿，在舞伴够不着物体时，更有可能帮助舞伴捡起物体。这太 remarquable 了。如果我们的动作与他们同步，他们会在过半的测试中提供帮助。而如果我们动作不同步，他们提供帮助的测试次数就会少于三分之一。如果你曾经和别人同步做过动作，你很可能是体验过这种驱动力的。比如在学校的运动乐队里，或者在仪仗队里。或者像劳拉一样作为一个舞者。这首歌是劳拉高中最后一次汇演的背景音乐，
which you dressed up as Mrs. Pots for a performance of Beauty and the Beast. There were many numbers in the performance, but in the Be Our Guest performance, everyone comes together all the little kitchen utensils and everything, and we do have to really synchronize at certain parts of the dance. And so when you're experiencing that, you really feel like you're part of this bigger group, and you're focusing on doing all of these steps, but that's become quite automatic at this point, and instead you can really sort of feel the connection with your co-dauncers, and you start to just ignore the audience completely, because you're part of this bigger thing.
当时她为了表演《美女与野兽》而装扮成茶煲太太。演出中有许多曲目，但在《欢迎光临》这个节目中，所有人都聚到了一起，所有的厨房小物件等等，我们在舞蹈的某些部分确实必须高度同步。所以当你经历这一切时，你真的会觉得自己是这个更大群体的一部分，你专注于完成所有这些舞步，但此时这些舞步已经变得相当自动化了，相反，你真的可以感受到与舞伴之间的连接，你开始完全忽略观众，因为你是这个宏大集体的一部分。
Come on and lift your glass, you want your own fee, pass to be our guest if you're stressed. Laura's fellow dancers remain some of her closest friends to this day. I'm going to be the MC at one of their weddings in September. So yeah, we we've definitely stayed very close. Music and dance create bonds because as Laura says, synchronous movement is a language of its own. This unspoken language can guide behavior even though many of us are not familiar with its syntax and vocabulary. I think music is providing a really interesting context where a lot of social cues are happening.
来吧，举起你的杯子，如果你感到压力，就接受我们的招待吧。直到今天，劳拉当年的舞伴依然是她最亲密的朋友。今年九月，我将担任他们其中一人婚礼的主持人。所以，是的，我们的关系确实一直非常密切。音乐和舞蹈创造了纽带，因为正如劳拉所说，同步的运动本身就是一种语言。这种无声的语言可以指导行为，尽管我们许多人并不熟悉它的句法和词汇。我认为音乐提供了一个非常有趣的背景，其中发生了许多社交线索。
So when we're moving with other people, when we're doing familiar things and singing familiar songs, these are actually queuing us, babies and adults, to think about the relationships that we have with these people. We think about teaching our kids to be pro-social and to be good citizens, but they're already attending to this information from a really early age.
所以当我们与其他人一起移动时，当我们做熟悉的事情、唱熟悉的歌时，这些其实都在提示我们——无论是婴儿还是成人——去思考我们与这些人之间的关系。我们考虑教导孩子成为亲社会的人、成为好公民，但他们其实从很小的年纪就已经在关注这些信息了。
The toddler experiment also shows that kids who can speak are still hungry to communicate. When a small child reaches out to pick up a marker or a paper ball, she may be saying, I like you, I want to help you. Let's be friends. I find babies are so impressive. We can't really ask them what they're thinking. We have to come up with clever ways of figuring out what's going on in their little brains and everybody of under-estimates them. Music and dance aren't the only ways adults and small kids communicate with one another.
学步儿的实验还表明，那些不会说话的孩子依然渴望交流。当一个小孩子伸手去捡记号笔或纸球时，她可能是在说：“我喜欢你，我想帮你。我们做朋友吧。”我发现婴儿太让人惊叹了。我们无法真正问他们在想什么。我们必须想出巧妙的方法，去弄清楚他们的小脑袋瓜里究竟在发什么，而每个人都低估了他们。音乐和舞蹈并不是成人与幼儿交流的唯一方式。
There's another language that actually sounds a lot like language. The traditional way of looking at babbling even as recently as 15, 20 years ago was really that it was just motor practice that it had no bearing on later language. It was just something babies did to exercise their mouths. This is Rachel Albert. I'm an assistant professor of psychology at Lebanon Valley College in Anvil, Pennsylvania. She studies infant language development. Those quote unquote traditional views on babbling.
还有另一种语言，听起来实际上非常像真正的语言。15、20年前，人们对咿呀学语的传统看法其实认为这只是单纯的肌肉练习，对后期的语言能力没有任何影响。这只是婴儿为了锻炼口腔而做的事情。这是雷切尔·阿尔伯特。我是宾夕法尼亚州安维尔黎巴嫩谷学院心理学系的助理教授。她研究婴儿语言发展。那些关于咿呀学语的所谓传统观点，
Rachel says toss them out. When babies babble, they're indicating that they're either in a heightened state of a rousal or by actually babbling, they're increasing their rousal level and putting themselves in kind of this optimal state of being ready to learn over and above than if they're just quietly looking at an object. Rachel says babbles have a certain jeunesseyix. Bonjour, toutez tous, je m'appelle Madame Macron. When she hears a baby Babel, she's taken back to high school French class. And I had one of those immersive French teachers who would only speak French in the classroom. And so it was really like being dropped into a non-native environment
雷切尔说，统统扔掉吧。当婴儿咿呀学语时，他们是在表明自己要么处于高度兴奋的状态，要么通过实际的咿呀学语，他们正在提高自己的兴奋水平，让自己进入一种随时准备学习的最佳状态，这比他们只是安静地看着一个物体要好得多。雷切尔说，婴儿的咿呀学语有一种独特的魅力。当她听到婴儿咿呀学语时，她被带回了高中法语课。我有一位那种沉浸式教学的法语老师，她在课堂上只说法语。所以那真的就像是被空投到一个非母语的环境中，
where you have to kind of figure things out. I vividly remember that she would come into the classroom and she would start talking and the whole class would have like stairs of panic as she would go and so she'd start slowing down her speech and pointing and labeling particular objects in the room. So she would in French be kind of pointing and saying, you know, are you sitting in a desk? Look at the desk. Here's a desk.
你必须自己把事情琢磨透。我清晰地记得，她走进教室开始说话，全班同学都会露出恐慌的表情，随着她继续说，她会开始放慢语速，并指向和说出房间里特定物体的名称。所以她会在法语里指着并说，你知道的，你是不是坐在课桌里？看这张课桌。这儿有一张课桌。
And kind of repeating those key vocabulary words until we start to figure out, oh, okay, this is the word for desk. Biore, biore, biore. And I thought, well, this must be somewhat similar to what a baby experiences, right, where there's all this conversation going around. Blah, blah, blah. They start to become active communication partners and trying to engage in that world, but how do they make sense of it?
并且不断重复那些核心词汇，直到我们开始明白：“哦，原来这是课桌的意思。” 当我听到“巴啦巴啦”的声音时，我想，这一定和婴儿所经历的有某种相似之处吧，到处都是这样的对话。他们开始成为积极的交流伙伴，并试图融入那个世界，但他们是如何理解这一切的呢？
Parents often see themselves as the know-it-all French teacher and the babbling baby as a clumsy student. Rachel says this framework is the one that's mostly used in studying infant language development. But the baby is applying as much of a role in this interaction as the mom. By changing the way that they babble and what they're looking at might actually be changing their opportunities for learning because they're changing what the parents say. It's kind of what we call a social feedback loop.
父母们通常把自己看作无所不知的法语老师，而把咿呀学语的婴儿看作笨拙的学生。雷切尔说，这种框架最常用于研究婴儿的语言发展。但婴儿在这场互动中发挥的作用和妈妈一样大。通过改变他们咿呀学语的方式以及他们注视的东西，他们实际上可能会改变自己的学习机会，因为他们改变了父母所说的话。这正是我们所谓的社会反馈循环。
So when the baby babbles, mom responds, the way mom responds actually will change in real time what the child says next. And they go around and around in this conversation influencing each other. There's a word to describe a back and forth exchange, where the thing that one person says affects what another person says. This feedback loop of communication and learning is what we call language. Babies make as many as a thousand vocalizations every day. On average, parents respond to about 60% of these babbles.
所以当婴儿咿呀学语时，妈妈会做出回应，妈妈回应的方式实际上会实时改变孩子接下来要说的话。他们在这个对话中周而复始地互相影响。有一个词用来描述这种双向交流，即一个人说的话会影响另一个人说的话。这种交流和学习的反馈循环就是我们所说的语言。婴儿每天会发出多达一千次的发声。平均而言，父母会对其中大约 60% 的咿呀学语做出回应。
Even just silently responding, if the mom just acknowledges the infants vocalization with a touch, On average, parents respond to about 60% of these babbles. Even just silently responding, if the mom just acknowledges the infant's vocalization with a touch, leans in smiles and touches the baby, the infant will immediately, within the span of just 10 minutes, start to produce more speech-like vocalizations, so that just that nonverbal feedback, that acknowledgement of the baby's vocalization, changes in the moment how they're babbling. Rachel says that when babies are babbling, they are more receptive to new information. Parents can take advantage of this by having conversations with their baby. And one rule of being a good conversationalist, stay attentive to what
甚至只是默默地回应，如果妈妈只是通过触摸来确认婴儿的发声，平均而言，父母会对其中大约 60% 的咿呀学语做出回应。甚至只是默默地回应，如果妈妈只是通过触摸来确认婴儿的发声，身体前倾、微笑并触碰婴儿，婴儿就会立刻——在短短 10 分钟的时间里——开始产生更多类似语音的发声，所以仅仅是那种非语言的反馈，对婴儿发声的确认，就会即时改变他们咿呀学语的方式。雷切尔说，当婴儿在咿呀学语时，他们对新信息的接受度更高。父母可以通过与婴儿对话来利用这一点。而成为一个好的对话者的法则之一，就是保持对
your partner is saying. So parents that are just talking constantly about irrelevant things that aren't what their child's looking at. For example, if a baby's looking at a ball and I'm talking about this cup over here that I'm playing with, well you're actually providing mismatching information for them that's going to make it harder to learn. Rachel says if you listen closely, babbling often falls into four distinct categories. They have different sounds and they elicit different responses. The first type is called QRV.
你的伴侣所说内容的关注。所以，如果父母只是不断地谈论一些不相干的事情，而不是孩子正在看的事情。例如，如果婴儿正在看一个球，而我在谈论我正在玩的这个杯子，那么你实际上是在为他们提供不匹配的信息，这会让他们更难学习。雷切尔说，如果你仔细倾听，婴儿的咿呀学语通常可以分为四种不同的类别。它们有不同的声音，也会引发不同的反应。第一种类型被称为 QRV。
QRV is the least mature infant vocalization, so the sounds are quasi-resident vocalization and so it's those really kind of nasal creaky kind of sounds that a lot of times parents interpret almost as fusing. The second type is called F-R-V. So that's a fully resonant vowel and around three or four months the baby's vocal track opens up and then they're able to produce those more open kind of adult like sounding vowels that kind of have those O's or A quality. And so parents recognize those as more speech-like than those first creaky nasalized vowels. And so they're more likely to respond to those.
QRV 是成熟度最低的婴儿发声，这些声音是准共振发声，也就是很多时候父母几乎将其解释为哭闹的那种带有鼻音的微弱声音。第二种类型被称为 F-R-V。也就是全共振元音，在三四个月左右，婴儿的声道会打开，然后他们能够发出那些更开放的、类似成人的元音，带有一种“哦”或“啊”的音质。因此，父母会认为这些比最初那些带鼻音的微弱元音更像语音。所以他们更有可能对这些做出回应。
The third is called MSFR. So that's a marginal syllable. And babies will start around six or so months throwing consonants into the mix. So you can hear in that sound there's kind of a DJ kind of sound, but it's a slow drawn out transition between when the consonant stops and when the vowel begins. And the pinnacle. The P-S-to-resistance, if you will. So that's what's called a canonical syllable. Those are those nice babas and dadas that parents naturally associate with babbling. And so babies start regularly producing those pretty frequently around nine months.
第三种被称为 MSFR。也就是边缘音节。大约六个月左右，婴儿会开始将辅音加入其中。所以你可以在那个声音中听到类似 DJ 的声音，但从辅音停止到元音开始，这是一个缓慢且拖长的过渡。而巅峰之作。可以说是压轴之作。这就是所谓的标准音节。也就是那些父母自然而然地与咿呀学语联系在一起的漂亮的“巴巴”和“达达”。因此，婴儿大约在九个月大时就会开始相当频繁地规律发出这些声音。
Parents react very strongly to these canonical syllables. They hear them as the most speech-like. They tend to often interpret them as approximations of words. So in that example, if a baby was holding a ball, a mom would be very likely to respond, oh, oh, that's a ball? Yep, you're right. That's a ball. a mom would be very likely to respond, oh, oh, that's a ball? Yep, you're right, that's a ball. You tried to say ball, that's great.
父母对这些标准音节的反应非常强烈。他们觉得这些声音最像语音。他们往往会把这些声音解释为对词语的近似表达。所以在那个例子中，如果婴儿手里拿着一个球，妈妈非常可能会回应：“哦，哦，那是个球？是的，你说的对。那是个球。”妈妈非常可能会回应：“哦，哦，那是个球？是的，你说的对，那是个球。你刚才想说球，太棒了。”
To Rachel, these different vocalizations are endlessly fascinating. Now that she knows how to telepath the QRVs from the FRVs and the MSFRs from the canonical syllables, she simply can't stop herself. On my wedding day, I remember very distinctly, I was in graduate school the time and need deep encoding this all the time, spending hours listening to these different sounds. And I remember being up at the front of the church about to say my vows and hearing some babies out in the audience, babble and kind of immediately coding it and going, oh, that was a marginal syllable.
对雷切尔来说，这些不同的发声有着无穷的魅力。既然她已经学会了如何从 FRV 中辨别 QRV，从标准音节中辨别 MSFR，她就完全无法控制自己了。在我的婚礼那天，我清晰地记得，我当时还在读研究生，整天都在深入研究这些，花几个小时聆听这些不同的声音。我记得当时我站在教堂前准备宣誓，听到台下有一些婴儿在咿呀学语，然后我本能地开始在脑海里分析并心想：“哦，那是边缘音节。”
And then thinking, no, focus. This is a very important moment. You're supposed to be attending to what you're past your saying. But I couldn't help but have my attention pulled by the baby in the audience and trying to code what she was saying. I'm trying to be a baby. I'm trying to be a baby.
然后又想：“不，集中注意力。这是一个非常重要的时刻。你应该关注你牧师说的话。”但我还是忍不住被台下婴儿的注意力吸引，并试图分析她在说什么。我试着像个婴儿一样。我试着像个婴儿一样。
I'm trying to be a baby. I'm trying to be a baby. I'm trying to be a baby. You don't have to memorize all the jargon to take away something valuable from the research. Just knowing that when babies are babbling, they're ready to learn, that can be a useful takeaway for everyone. When we return, we discuss two final elements of baby language. One is going to make you very happy. The other? Well, that's something you don't want to hear as you're saying your wedding
我试着像个婴儿一样。我试着像个婴儿一样。我试着像个婴儿一样。你不需要记住所有的专业术语，就能从这项研究中获得有价值的收获。只要知道当婴儿在咿呀学语时，他们就准备好学习了，这个收获对每个人都很有用。当我们回来时，我们将讨论婴儿语言的最后两个要素。其中一个会让你非常开心。另一个呢？嗯，那是你在宣誓时最不想听到的声音。
bows. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This hour we are demystifying the behavior of young children. And we begin this next segment with a warning. If you're driving or listening to the story while cooking, you're about to hear something very distracting.
你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是美国国家公共电台。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这一小时我们将揭秘幼儿的行为。我们以一个警告开启接下来的环节。如果你正在开车，或者一边做饭一边听这个故事，你接下来会听到一些非常容易让人分心的事情。
This is Katrina Doudna of Sunnyvale, California. It's dinner time. She's throwing a tantrum because she wants to sit at the head of the table. Problem is, the table's round. There is no head. When she was in midst of a tantrum, she picked something that she knew was completely unreasonable. I don't want my feet. Take my feet off. I don't want my feet. I don't want my feet." That's Katrina's mom, Noemi. She talked with me a number of years ago about her then three-year-old daughter. I once teased her, which is a turn out to be a big mistake, but I once said, Okay, let's go get some scissors and take care of your feet. No!
这是加利福尼亚州森尼韦尔的卡特里娜·杜德纳。现在是晚餐时间。她正在发脾气，因为她想坐在桌子的首位。问题是，桌子是圆的。根本没有首位。当她大发雷霆时，她挑了一件她明知完全不合理的事情。“我不要我的脚。把我的脚拿掉。我不要我的脚。我不要我的脚。”那是卡特里娜的妈妈诺埃米。多年前她曾和我聊起她当时三岁的女儿。我曾经逗过她，结果证明这是一个巨大的错误，但我曾经说过：“好吧，我们去拿把剪刀来把你的脚处理掉吧。” “不要！”
My curiosity was focused on what are the elements of the tantrums, you know, the snips and snails and puppy dog tails or what. This is Mike. It's Mike Potegal. I am currently an associate professor in program and occupational therapy at University of Minnesota. Mike was inspired to study tantrums after witnessing his own daughters, operatic meltdowns. Among the things that I learned from that was that there was a sequence in which various behaviors appeared, various behaviors of which tantrums are composed. Just like Rachel Albert did with babbling, Mike picked out a rhythm in the cacophony of his daughter's tantrums.
我的好奇心集中在脾气发作的组成部分上，你知道的，是粗剪、蜗牛还是小狗尾巴之类的东西。这是迈克。我是迈克·波特加尔。我目前是明尼苏达大学职业治疗项目的副教授。迈克在目睹了自己的女儿们史诗般的崩溃后，受到了启发去研究发脾气。我从中学到的一件事是，各种行为出现是有先后顺序的，构成发脾气的各种行为。就像雷切尔·阿尔伯特对待咿呀学语那样，迈克从他女儿发脾气的交响乐中挑出了一个节奏。
To prove his point, he teamed up with a colleague, James Green. He's a psychologist at the University of Connecticut. We developed a one Z that toddlers can wear that has a high quality wireless microphone sewn into it. Parents put this onesy on the child and press a go button on the equipment. And then they waited for a meltdown. James and Mike recorded more than a hundred of them and what they found confirmed their hypothesis. There are two major emotional, I think of them as
为了证明他的观点，他与同事詹姆斯·格林联手了。他是康涅狄格大学的心理学家。我们开发了一种连体衣，学步儿可以穿上它，里面缝入了一个高质量的无线麦克风。父母把这件连体衣穿在孩子身上，然后按下设备上的“开始”按钮。接着他们就等待崩溃的发生。詹姆斯和迈克记录了一百多次这样的崩溃，他们发现的结果证实了他们的假设。脾气发作有两个主要的感情成分，我认为它们是
emotional behavioral components of tantrums. The first is anger, hitting, kicking, screaming, throwing things, pushing and pulling. And the other component is distress. Wining, crying, throwing the self down that is dropping to the floor, and comfort seeking. Don't confuse these components with stages. Mike says the behaviors occur simultaneously. The distress is more consistent. Throughout the tantrum, from its beginning to its end.
情绪行为成分。第一种是愤怒：打人、踢人、尖叫、扔东西、推搡和拉扯。另一个成分是痛苦：呜咽、哭泣、把自己扔在地上（也就是摔倒在地上）以及寻求安慰。不要把这些成分和阶段混为一谈。迈克说这些行为是同时发生的。痛苦表现得更持续。贯穿整个发脾气的过程，从开始到结束。
The anger punctuates the tantrum. It provides the dramatic spikes, and it also tapers toward the end. In every case, the anger terminates before the distress. In every case, the anger terminates before the distress. Mike says there's a reason that most tantrums end with a distress call. Because the distress, sadness, tends to elicit comfort giving. And so it would make sense from an evolutionary perspective if the anger which is disruptive is smooth over by the stress component which then other things
愤怒则是在发脾气过程中起标点作用。它带来了戏剧性的高潮，并且在接近尾声时逐渐减弱。在每一种情况下，愤怒都在痛苦之前结束。在每一种情况下，愤怒都在痛苦之前结束。迈克说，大多数发脾气都以痛苦的呼喊结束是有原因的。因为痛苦和悲伤往往会引发安慰的给予。所以从进化的角度来看，如果具有破坏性的愤怒被痛苦成分所平息，在其他条件相同的情况下，这就会呼唤父母来安慰孩子。让我们回到卡特里娜·杜德纳，一个三岁的小 maestro，她因为不能坐在家里圆形餐桌的首位而大发雷霆。爸爸试图和她讲道理。詹姆斯·格林说他以前也陷入过同样的陷阱。当孩子们处于愤怒的顶峰，尖叫和踢打时，
equal will call for parent comforting the child. Let's go back to Katrina Doudna, a three-year-old Maestra who's throwing a fit because she can't sit at the head of the family's circular dining table. Dad tries to reason with him. James Green says that he's fallen into the same trap before. When children are at the peak of anger and they're screaming and they're kicking, When children are at the peak of anger and they're screaming and they're kicking, probably asking questions, um, might prolong that period of anger. Dad decides to intervene. I'm going to take you in this chair for you.
当孩子们处于愤怒的顶峰，尖叫和踢打时，此时提问可能会延长那段愤怒的时间。爸爸决定介入。“我要把你抱到这把椅子上。”
Now Katrina's on the floor. She grabs a stool and slams it against the wall. It seems like things are escalating, but James says it's just the opposite. Once she's thrown herself on the floor and thrown something or in this case knock the chair against the wall, we're probably on the downslope of this tantrum. She's spent a lot of energy screaming, yelling, and now doing these physical behaviors. Listen to Katrina and Pay attention to how the register of her voice changes. Mike says in many cases, parents can safely ignore their child's tantrums. And this approach has a formal name planned ignoring, and it basically means turning your back on the child and walking out of the room. Because talking to them and telling them to stop is giving them attention, albeit negative
现在卡特里娜躺在地上了。她抓起一张凳子朝墙上猛砸。事情看起来在升级，但詹姆斯说恰恰相反。一旦她把自己摔在地板上，扔了东西，或者在这个例子中把椅子撞向墙上，我们可能就已经处于这次发脾气的下行阶段了。她通过尖叫、大喊以及现在的这些身体行为消耗了大量的能量。听听卡特里娜的声音，注意她声音的音调是如何变化的。迈克说，在许多情况下，父母可以安全地忽视孩子发脾气。这种方法有一个正式的名称——计划性忽视，它基本上意味着背对孩子并走出房间。因为和他们说话并叫他们停下来就是在给他们关注，尽管是负面的关注。
attention. This works best when the child throws a tantrum to get attention, or because you've said no to eating cookies at dinner. But if the child throws a tantrum in response to something you've asked them to do, A very different approach is appropriate. And the reason for that is that what the tantrum does, it's basically a stall.
当孩子是为了引起注意而发脾气，或者因为你拒绝让他们在晚餐时吃饼干时，这种方法效果最好。但如果孩子是因为你要求他们做某事而发脾气，那么就需要采取完全不同的方法。原因在于，发脾气的作用本质上是一种拖延。
It's a way for the child to not comply with the parent request. And so the best approach, if it can be managed, is to get the child to comply with the request. And so the best approach, if it can be managed, is to get the child to comply with the request. For younger children, this can be done with a hand over hand kind of forced cooperation. So you can say to the child, okay, get your PJs on. And if the child refuses, you can say, okay, I'm going to count to three or five or whatever you like. And if you have not begun putting your PJs on, I'm going to put my hands on your hands
这是孩子不服从父母要求的一种方式。所以最好的方法（如果能做到的话）是让孩子服从要求。所以最好的方法（如果能做到的话）是让孩子服从要求。对于较小的孩子，这可以通过手把手式的强迫合作来完成。所以你可以对孩子说：“好了，把睡衣穿上。”如果孩子拒绝，你可以说：“好吧，我要数到三或五，随你喜欢。如果你还没有开始穿睡衣，我会把我的手放在你的手上帮你穿。”孩子们非常讨厌这样。
and help you do it. And children really do not like this. Because he says it's a threat to their autonomy, and if the child still doesn't comply, maybe you can use it as an opportunity to do some research, just like Mike. We would walk down the street and I'd see a kid having a tantrum and I would mutter or say out loud to my wife, data, and then, of course, she'd give me a side-long look without what's wrong with you. Yeah. We've talked so far about the secret languages of dancing and babbling.
因为他说这是对他们自主权的威胁，如果孩子仍然不听话，也许你可以利用这个机会做点研究，就像迈克一样。我们会走在街上，看到一个孩子在大发脾气，我会小声嘟囔或者大声对我的妻子说：“数据。”然后，当然，她会斜眼看我一眼，心想：你脑子是不是有毛病？是的。我们到目前为止讨论了舞蹈和咿呀学语的秘密语言。
We've looked at the grammar of temper tantrums. Now we turn to lullabies. Laura Cerelli, the first researcher we featured on Dancing and Synchronization, has also done work on the language of music with infants. Across cultures, we all engage with music, and we do it at such an early age. So we really wanted to continue to explore this idea that one of the real benefits and perhaps one of the underlying reasons why we invest so much time in energy and music across cultures is because of these social and emotional implications.
我们研究了发脾气的语法。现在我们转向催眠曲。劳拉·瑟雷利，我们介绍的第一位研究舞蹈和同步性的研究人员，也对婴儿的音乐语言进行过研究。跨越不同的文化，我们所有人都会接触音乐，而且我们在很小的年纪就开始这么做了。所以我们真的很想继续探讨这个观点，即跨文化投入大量时间和精力在音乐上的真正好处之一，也是潜在原因之一，正是因为这些社会和情感层面的影响。
Remember the magic of the cleanup song that Laura talked about earlier? She and her fellow researchers wanted to closely examine the effect of music on babies and their caregivers. They asked parents to volunteer to come into the lab with their babies. 30 mothers said they would do it. They would be in a sound proof room, and babies would be sat in a little high chair and moms would sit facing them. They were also measuring stress levels. So we used little stickers on the bottom of the baby's foot and on the mother's fingertips. And what we're able to measure with this is actually there's sweat gland activity.
还记得劳拉之前谈到的那首神奇的收拾玩具歌吗？她和同事们希望仔细研究音乐对婴儿及其看护者的影响。他们招募了自愿带着婴儿来到实验室的父母。30位母亲表示愿意参与。她们将处于一个隔音房间里，婴儿坐在婴儿高脚椅上，妈妈则坐在他们对面。他们还在测量压力水平。所以我们在婴儿脚底和母亲指尖贴了小贴纸。通过这个我们可以测量到的是汗腺活动。
The mother is then sang two versions of Twinkle Twinkle Little Star, one version. Twinkle Twinkle Little Star. How I wonder what you are. The other. Twinkle Twinkle Little Star. What's a lala bada? How I wonder what you are. What's a lullaby?
然后母亲唱了两个版本的《小星星》，一个版本是：小星星，亮晶晶，我很好奇你是什么。另一个版本：小星星，亮晶晶，什么是个拉拉巴巴？我很好奇你是什么，什么是催眠曲？
What we found was that when mom sang in a playful way, both mom and babies arousal levels stayed stable. But when mom sang in a soothing way, both mom and babies arousal levels decreased as the song progressed. So what's this, this is telling us is that lullabies are really working to calm not only baby but also the mother. And so this supports this idea that there's a function here. Is this telling us just what, is this just confirming what our intuitions are telling us or
我们发现，当妈妈以游戏般的方式唱歌时，妈妈和婴儿的兴奋水平都保持稳定。但当妈妈以舒缓的方式唱歌时，随着歌曲的进行，妈妈和婴儿的兴奋水平都下降了。所以这说明了什么，这告诉我们催眠曲确实不仅能让婴儿平静下来，也能让母亲平静下来。这就支持了这里存在某种功能的观点。这究竟是在告诉我们什么，这只是证实了我们的直觉，还是
do you think is telling us something more than that? And it totally, I'm sure most parents would agree that little by suit their babies. But usually when we're singing little by suit to our babies, we're holding them and we're rocking them and we're adding all of this really important soothing tactile information. So we wanted to know what the song is doing, removing all of that tactile input. So the babies are sitting in the high chair, they're facing their mom, but they're not experiencing that holding and that rocking, that typically comes along with all the bias. But I think the really interesting thing here is we usually think of that unidirectional relationship like when mom's saying to babies it is to change the baby's behavior.
你认为它告诉了我们比这更多的东西？毫无疑问，大多数父母都会同意催眠曲能安抚他们的婴儿。但通常当我们唱催眠曲安抚婴儿时，我们是在抱着他们、摇晃他们，并且加入了所有这些非常重要的舒缓的触觉信息。所以我们想知道，剥离掉所有这些触觉输入后，单靠歌曲本身能起到什么作用。所以婴儿们坐在高脚椅上，面对着他们的妈妈，但他们没有体验到通常伴随催眠曲而来的抱抱和摇晃。但我觉得这里最有趣的是，我们通常认为那是一种单向关系，比如当妈妈对婴儿唱歌时，是为了改变婴儿的行为。
But I think it's the really new interesting thing here is considering how it's also affecting the mom. Indeed, if there's one thing that all this research shows is that communicating with babies is not a one-way street. Parents and caregivers are shaped by what babies say and sing and scream, just as babies are hungrily soaking up information from adults. When we think about raising a human, it's natural that most of us think about the role that adults play in shaping their children. What's less clear, but what is abundantly true, is
但我觉得这里全新且有趣的地方在于，去思考它同时是如何影响母亲的。事实上，如果说这项研究说明了什么，那就是与婴儿交流绝不是单行道。父母和看护者会被婴儿说的话、唱的歌和尖叫声所塑造，正如婴儿正像海绵一样急切地从成人那里吸收信息一样。当我们思考抚养一个人类时，我们大多数人自然会去想成年人在塑造孩子方面所扮演的角色。不太清楚但却绝对真实的是，
that babies are every bit is involved in raising humans of their own. It's not just a figure of speech, we're all always growing up. When we come back, while less is sometimes more, when it comes to helping children learn. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Step into the basement of Alex Hamilton's home in Frederick, Maryland, and you'll notice it has a distinct smell.
婴儿在抚养他们自己的下一代人类这件事上，同样参与其中。这绝不仅仅是一个修辞手法，我们所有人都在不断长大。稍后回来，有时“少即是多”，当涉及到帮助孩子学习时。你收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。这里是美国国家公共电台。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。走进马里兰州弗雷德里克市亚历克斯·汉密尔顿家里的地下室，你会注意到这里有一种独特的味道。
It's wood dust and cigars. The wood dust? That's from his carpentry projects. Alex's basement is his workshop. He's built things for every room in his house and outside too. Alex is showing my producer Rina Cohen around. Today he's building something for a beloved family member. One of my dogs likes to go with me everywhere, so I'm making a bike seat just for her.
那是木屑和雪茄味。木屑？那是他做木工活留下的。亚历克斯的地下室就是他的工作室。他为家里的每一个房间甚至室外都制作过东西。亚历克斯正在带我的制作人丽娜·科恩参观。今天他正在为一位深爱的家庭成员制作东西。我的一条狗喜欢去哪里都跟着我，所以我正在为它制作一个专属的自行车座椅。
Alex calls himself a retired perfectionist. Things don't have to be perfect for you to enjoy them. That's especially true for another of Alex's hobbies. Garden is out here. He steps outside his house to show us. A sausage of a dog scampers up. Butter bean. That's my garden helper.
亚历克斯自称是一个退休的完美主义者。事情不需要做到完美你也能享受它们。对于亚历克斯的另一个爱好来说，尤其如此。菜园就在外面。他走到屋外给我们展示。一只像香肠一样的狗小跑过来。黄豆。那是我的园艺小助手。
Alex walks around his garden, pointing out the fruits and vegetables he's planted. Those are blackberries. Broccoli. Sugar, baby watermelon. Artechokes. Maybe not Artechokes. Had one Artechoke plant and there was a rabbit who kept eating it down to the ground and a couple weeks later it would grow to be two or three inches tall and then the rabbit would come back and eat it all the way down the ground.
亚历克斯在菜园里走来走去，指出他种的水果和蔬菜。那是黑莓。西兰花。糖宝西瓜。洋蓟。也许不是洋蓟。我曾经有一株洋蓟苗，结果有只兔子一直在把它啃到贴地，几星期后它会长高两三英寸，然后兔子又会跑回来把它啃得精光。
So good for him. I still haven't seen what an artichoke plant looks like. This pesky rabbit is one of the variables that distinguishes Alex's gardening from his carpentry. When he's in his workshop, there are things that he can control. The humidity, the shape, the size, the color. But as a gardener, he's found he has to let go. You can't control the weather. You can't control your rain.
所以算它厉害。我到现在还没见过洋蓟长什么样呢。这只讨厌的兔子是把亚历克斯的园艺和木工区分开来的变量之一。当他在工作室里时，有些事情是他可以控制的。湿度、形状、大小、颜色。但作为一个园艺爱好者，他发现自己必须学会放手。你无法控制天气。你无法控制下雨。
You can't control the humidity. So I would say more than half of the variables for gardening, you have absolutely no control. Carpenters draft plans and stick to them. Gardeners, well... You have things that creep up on you all the time. Surprises are what make gardening so frustrating. Those weeds are really awful. I hate those things. But surprises are also what make gardening so rewarding.
你无法控制湿度。所以我想，园艺中有一半以上的变量是你完全无法控制的。木匠会画好图纸并严格执行。而园艺师嘛……总有一些事情会出其不意地找上你。惊喜正是让园艺如此令人沮丧的原因。那些杂草真的很讨厌。我恨死那些东西了。但惊喜也是让园艺如此充满回报的原因。
All these flowers here started from one flower and they propagated. So at the end of the summer we had this beautiful flower bed and we didn't have to do anything. Alex Hamilton's hobbies are a metaphor for something very different. According to Berkeley Psychology Professor Alison Gopnik, the different philosophies of the carpenter and the gardener play out every day in how parents interact with their children. In her book, The Gardener and the Carpenter, Addison looks at two approaches to being a parent
这里所有的花都是从一朵花开始繁殖的。所以在夏天结束时，我们拥有了这个美丽的苗圃，而我们什么都没做。亚历克斯·汉密尔顿的爱好是某种完全不同事物的隐喻。根据伯克利大学心理学教授艾莉森·戈普尼克的说法，木匠和园艺师的不同哲学每天都在父母与孩子的互动中上演。在其著作《园艺师与木匠》中，艾莉森审视了两种为人父母的方法
and their consequences. Your book is built around an analogy. Parents behaving like gardeners, parents behaving like carpenters. Unpack those analogies for me. Well, if you look at the prevailing culture of parents and caregiving in the United States, it's a picture that's a lot like the picture you might imagine if you thought about a carpenter. And the idea is that if you just do the right things, get the right skills, read the right
以及它们带来的后果。你的书是围绕一个类比展开的。父母表现得像园艺师，父母表现得像木匠。为我拆解一下这些类比吧。嗯，如果你看看美国当前主流的父母和育儿文化，你会发现这幅画很像当你想到木匠时可能会想象到的画面。这种观点认为，如果你只是做了对的事，掌握了正确的技能，阅读了正确的书
books, you're going to be able to shape your child into a particular kind of adult. And that picture is very different from the kind of picture that comes from the science. The picture that comes from the science is much more like being a gardener. Now one thing about being a gardener is you never know what's going to happen in the garden, the things that you plan fail, but then wonderful things happen that you haven't actually planned. And there's actually a deeper reason for that. And the reason is that what being a gardener is all about is creating a rich, nurturing, but also variable, diverse, dynamic ecosystem in which many, many different things can happen, and a system that can respond to the environment in unpredictable kind of ways. And I think the science suggests that being a caregiver for human beings is much more like being a gardener than being a carpenter. It's much more about providing
书本，你就能把你的孩子塑造成某种特定类型的成年人。而这幅图景与科学所得出的图景截然不同。科学得出的图景更像是成为一名园丁。关于园丁，有一点是无论如何你都无法预知花园里会发生什么，你计划的事情会失败，但接着美妙的事情就会发生，而这些其实并不是你计划好的。这背后其实有一个更深层的原因。原因在于，当园丁的全部意义在于创造一个丰富、滋养，同时也充满变数、多样化、动态的生态系统，在这个系统中可以发生许许多多不同的事情，并且这个系统能够以不可预测的方式对环境作出反应。我认为科学表明，作为人类的照顾者，与其说是像木匠，倒不如说更像是园丁。它更多的是关于提供
a protected space in which unexpected things can happen than it is like shaping a child to come out to be a particular kind of desirable at all. I was surprised to read that the term parenting itself isn't very old. When did the term become popular and how did it come to be? Yeah, it's interesting, the very word parenting, which seems so ubiquitous and taken for granted now, is actually quite recent. So if you look in Google Engram, it's only around the 1970s in America that the word first begins to really take off and then there's this kind of exponential increase from the 70s up to the present moment. This is Focus on the Family hosted by psychologist Dr. James Dobson, the author of such best-selling books on the family as parenting isn't for cowards. Hey parents, listen up to this. This could be
一个受保护的空间，在这个空间里可能会发生意想不到的事情，而不是像把孩子塑造成为某种特定令人向往的人那样。我很惊讶地读到，“育儿”（parenting）这个词本身其实并不算太古老。这个词是什么时候开始流行的，它又是如何演变而来的呢？是的，这很有趣，“育儿”这个词现在看起来无处不在且被视为理所当然，但实际上相当年轻。如果你在谷歌图书用语检索（Google Ngram）中查看，就会发现大约在20世纪70年代的美国，这个词才开始真正流行起来，然后从70年代到目前呈现出一种指数级的增长。这里是《聚焦家庭》（Focus on the Family），由心理学家詹姆斯·多布森（James Dobson）博士主持，他是畅销书《养育孩子不是懦夫的事》（Parenting Isn't for Cowards）等家庭书籍的作者。嘿，父母们，听好了。这可能是
revolutionary. You have to change the way you think about parenting because Amy Chu I ignited a firestorm by sharing the surprising details of her strict parenting methods in the book, Battle Him of the Tiger Mother. And if you think about it, parenting is a kind of strange word. After all, we don't whive our husbands or child our parents. What we say is that those are relationships. I am a child or I am a wife. It's not a kind of gold-directed activity that I'm doing that has a particular outcome that I'm trying to achieve.
具有革命性的。你必须改变你对育儿的看法，因为艾米·楚（Amy Chua）在《虎妈战歌》（Battle Hymn of the Tiger Mother）一书中分享了她严厉育儿方法的惊人细节，从而点燃了一场风暴。如果你仔细想想，育儿（parenting）是个有点奇怪的词。毕竟，我们不会去“丈夫化”（whive）我们的丈夫，也不会去“孩子化”（child）我们的父母。我们所说的是，这些都是关系。我是一个孩子，或者我是一个妻子。它不是那种由我正在做的、试图达到特定结果的以目标为导向的活动。
And I think being a parent is a much better way of describing what that relationship is all about than parenting, then changing a child into something else. So it's interesting that that switch in some ways to a verb changes what we think about the activity. As you say, we don't start a friendship saying, in three years' time, I want my friend to become X, and I'm going to raise my friend to become that person that I want him or her to be. Yeah, in fact, if you think about something like a friendship, of course, it's when friends are in bad shape that the friendship counts the most. I think there was actually a historical reason why the word appeared in the late 20th century and the culture that goes along with it, which has become more and more intense, even in
我认为，用“父母”（being a parent）来形容这种关系的全部意义，要比“育儿”（parenting）——也就是把孩子变成别的东西——好得多。所以很有趣的是，在某些方面，转变为一个动词改变了我们对这项活动的看法。正如你所说，我们不会在开始一段友谊时说：“三年后，我希望我的朋友变成X，我要把我的朋友抚养成我希望他或她成为的那个人。”是的，事实上，如果你想想友谊之类的东西，当然，正是当朋友处于糟糕状态时，友谊才最重要。我认为历史上有个原因导致这个词在20世纪后期出现，并伴随着这种文化，这种文化变得越来越强烈，甚至在我有自己的孩子的这30年里也是如此。我认为原因在于，在人类历史上，人们第一次生孩子，尤其是那些以前没有太多照顾孩子经验的中产阶级美国人。所以，从科学中得出的另一个观点是，只要我们还是人类，大哥哥大姐姐、表亲、姑姑、祖母以及整个村庄都参与其中
the 30 years since I had my own children. And I think that reason is that for the first time in human history, people were having children, especially middle class American people people who had not had much experience of caring for children before. So one of the things, again, that comes out of the sciences for as long as we've been human, older brothers and sisters and cousins and aunts and grandmothers and the whole village has been involved
来照顾孩子。这意味着在人类历史的大部分时间里，当你自己准备好生孩子时，你已经有了很多照顾孩子的实践经验。这意味着在人类历史的大部分时间里，当你自己准备好生孩子时，你已经有了很多照顾孩子的实践经验。你也看过许多不同的人，不仅仅是你自己的父母，还有许多其他人照顾孩子。20世纪发生的事情是，由于家庭规模变小，人们流动性更强，而且人们生育年龄更晚。人们第一次生孩子时，并没有太多照顾孩子的经验，但却有着丰富的
in caring for children. And that meant that for most of human history, by the time you were ready to have children yourself, you'd had lots of practical experience in caring for children. And that meant that for most of human history, by the time you were ready to have children yourself, you'd had lots of practical experience in caring for children. You'd also watched lots of different people, not just your own parents, but many other people care for children. And what happened in the 20th century was because families got smaller, and people got to be more mobile, and people had children at a later age. For the first time, people were having children who hadn't had much experience of caring for children, but had had lots of experience
上学和工作经验。所以我想人们自然会想：“哦，好吧，我要做的这件事，就像上学和工作一样，如果我能找到合适的手册或秘密秘籍，我就会在这项任务上取得成功，就像我在课堂上或工作中取得成功一样。”
of going to school and working. So I think it was kind of natural for people to think, oh, okay, this thing that I'm about to do, this is like going to school and working, and if I can just find the right manual or the right secret handbook, I'm gonna succeed at this task, the same way that I succeeded in my classes or I succeeded in my job.
所以我认为，历史事实很大程度上解释了为什么这种文化，以及随之而来的这种焦虑、担忧感，还有这个价值数十亿美元的育儿产业，会在20世纪末开始涌现。艾莉森指出，与其他灵长类动物相比，人类有着特别长的童年。我们只是理所当然地认为孩子需要被照顾很长时间，但这实际上在进化上是一个悖论。这里有一个有趣的问题，那就是为什么会这样？至少有一个想法是，拥有这段漫长的童年期为你提供了一个受保护的时期，让你能够适应一个新的环境。
So I think that historical fact is a lot of the reason why this culture and with it this kind of sense of anxiety and worry and also this billion dollar parenting industry all started emerging at the end of the 20th century. emerging at the end of the 20th century. Alison points out that compared to other primates, humans have an especially long childhood. We just sort of take it for granted that children need to be taken care of for a long time, but that's actually sort of evolutionarily paradoxical. And there's an interesting question about why it did that happen. And one idea at least is that having that long period of childhood gave you this protected period where you could figure out a new environment.
你可以搬家，比方说从一个村庄搬到另一个村庄，或者从一个地方搬到另一个地方，而童年给了你掌握这个新环境的机会。我认为，关于孩子那些看似奇怪的事情——他们既极其富有创造力、充满想象力、极具探索精神，却又如此不善于照顾自己——在某种程度上都符合这幅图景。你认为父母试图成为木匠会带来什么害害处？嗯，我是说，这是一个棘手的问题。
You could move, say, from one village to another, or from one place to another, and childhood gave you a chance to master that new environment. And I think that a lot of the things that seem kind of strange about children, the fact that they're simultaneously so creative, so imaginative, so exploratory, and yet so bad at taking care of themselves, kind of fit that picture. What do you think the harm is of parents trying to be carpenters? Well, I mean, it's a tricky question.
我认为主要的害处在于，它让身为父母的过程和生活变得焦虑、困难、紧张，并在各种不必要的方面感到不快乐。我认为这让父母感到如此，也让孩子感到如此。现在，关于父母的任何行为在长远来看如何影响孩子，这是一个非常非常复杂的问题。所以这幅进化图景的另一个部分是，每个独立的儿童都有他们自己的特征，每个父母也是如此。父母独特的特征与
I think the main harm is that it makes the process the life of being a parent anxious and difficult and tense and unhappy in all sorts of ways that are unnecessary. And I think it makes it that way for parents and it makes it that way for children. Now, the question about how any kind of behavior on the part of parents influences children in the long run is very, very complicated. So another piece of this evolutionary picture is that every individual child has their own characteristics, every parent does. There's this complicated interaction between the parents' distinctive characteristics in
孩子的特征之间存在着这种复杂的互动，以至于实际上想要说：“嗯，如果你这样做，那么你的孩子长远来看就会变成那样。”这基本上是一场稳输的游戏，而且我认为我们没有太多的证据来支持这一点。所以我不想说：“啊，好吧，如果你是个木匠，那么你的孩子就会长成某种可怕、疯狂的模样。”孩子们会以各种意想不到的方式成长。这就是重点所在。这不仅仅是木匠模型让父母和孩子感到压力山大。
the child's, so that actually trying to say, well, if you do this, then your child is going to come out like that in the long run. That's pretty much of a mugs game, and I don't think we have very much evidence for that. So I wouldn't want to say, ah, well, if you're a carpenter, then your children are going to come out and have some terrible, crazy feature. Children come out in all sorts of unexpected ways. That's the whole point. It's not just that the carpentry model is making parents and kids stressed.
艾莉森注意到了当今青少年的一些现象。你知道，在某些方面，他们做得更好。他们的成就更高。他们怀孕或吸毒的可能性更小。但这也伴随着一种焦虑，高度的焦虑，高度的恐惧。我想这正是你会从木匠的故事中预测到的情况。所以木匠的故事是这样的：你如此关心孩子的成长结果，以至于你没有
There's something Addison has noticed about today's adolescence. You know, in some ways, they're doing much better. They're achieving more. They're less likely to get pregnant or to use drugs. But that goes with a kind of anxiety, high levels of anxiety, high levels of fear. And I think that is kind of what you would predict from the Carpentry story. So the Carpentry story is one where you're so concerned that the child come out, that you're not
给孩子冒险、探索和自主的自由。如果不承担一些真正出错的可能性，那就不能叫冒险。我认为这是当前育儿文化中另一个存在问题的地方。我们如此关心这些孩子最终会变成什么样，以至于我们不愿意给予他们自主权，让他们能够去冒险并探索世界。所以，我在想，这其中是否有些与你作为父母的目标有关。我认为你所表达的观点是，通过创建一个孩子们可以学习和探索的环境，你培养出的孩子可能不那么焦虑、更有韧性，更能应对眼前的生活变故。我理解这一点，
giving the child the freedom to take risks and explore and be autonomous. And it's not risk-taking unless there's some chance that it could really go wrong. And I think that's another aspect of the current parenting culture that's problematic. We're so concerned about how these children are going to turn out, that we're unwilling to give them the autonomy that they need to be able to take risks and go out and explore the world. So, I'm wondering if some of this has to do with what your goals are as a parent. The point that I think you're making is that by creating an environment where children can learn and explore, you build children who perhaps are going to be less anxious, more resilient, more able to deal with the vagaries of life in front of them. And I get that,
这确实说得通。但还有这样一种情况，我认为我们的世界奖励那些能够做非常具体的事情并且把它们做得非常好的人。所以，你知道，每四年奥运会就会到来，当我看到在奥运会上赢得金牌的人时，那些通常是三岁就开始上滑冰课的孩子。或者你看到有人加入了你所在城镇的管弦乐队，那个人是四岁就开始上钢琴课的。这些是非常具体的技能，我认为这些技能很难学习，需要花费大量的时间、奉献精神和练习。如果你没有真正投入时间去尽早做到这一点，那么以后就很难掌握这些
and that does make sense. But there's also the case that I think our world rewards people who can do very specific things and do them very well. So, you know, every four years the Olympics comes along when I see people who are winning gold medals in the Olympics, those are usually kids who've started ice skating lessons when they were three. Or you see someone who is joining the orchestra in your town and that someone who has started piano lessons when she was four. And there are these very specific skills that I think are very hard to learn and take an enormous amount of time and dedication and practice. And if you don't actually invest the time to do that early, it becomes very hard to master those
技能。尽管你可能会说，“让孩子自己去搞清楚他或她可能想做什么”，但如果一个孩子在14岁时发现自己真的很想成为一名滑冰运动员或芭蕾舞演员，那么在那个时候要想真正擅长它可能已经太晚了。我在想，这里的某些紧张关系是否源于我们实际的目标是什么。我们的目标是培养适应良好的孩子，还是培养成功的孩子？我希望这两者之间没有冲突，但我有时觉得它们可能确实存在。嗯，这很有趣。
skills later on. And even though you might say, you know, let the child figure out what it is he or she might want to do, if a child discovers that she really wants to be an ice skater or a ballet dancer when she's 14, it's probably too late at that point to really be very good at it. And I'm wondering if some of the tension here comes from what it is that we're actually aiming for. Are we aiming for children who are well-adjusted versus aiming for children who are successful? And I wish there was an attention between those two things, but I sometimes think they might be. Well, it's interesting.
毫无疑问，育儿方法背后的某种文化背景是：父母有一种身处高度竞争世界的感觉，在这个世界里，例如在教育方面给孩子带来微小的优势，对于确保孩子能够继续保持在中产阶级或中上阶层地位至关重要。日益加剧的不平等，以及这种不平等与
There's no question that part of the kind of cultural background for the parenting approach. Is this sense that parents have of being in a very competitive universe where small advantages to their children in terms of their education, for example, are going to be absolutely crucial to make sure that the children continue to be in the middle class of the upper middle class. The combination of increasing inequality and increasing relationship between that inequality
学业成就等事物之间日益紧密的联系，我认为这给中产阶级父母带来了巨大的压力，让他们确保孩子能够踏上那条学业成功的轨道。正是在父母认为自己在帮助孩子学习的那些时刻，他们实际上可能在阻碍孩子。艾莉森描述了一个实验，展示了当大人主导或袖手旁观时究竟会发生什么。
and things like academic achievement, I think puts a great deal of stress on middle class parents to make sure that their children get into that academic achievement track. The very moments when parents think they're helping their kids learn, they may in fact stand in the way. Allison described an experiment that shows just what happens when adults take the lead or hang back.
这是伊丽莎白·博诺维茨（Elizabeth Bonawitz）和劳拉·舒尔茨（Laura Schulz）所做的工作，他们向孩子们展示了一个复杂的东西，它可以做很多不同的事情。它会发出吱吱声，有一个镜子，还有一个灯。问题是，孩子们会发现这个玩具能做的所有事情吗？他们发现，如果你把这样一个复杂的玩具给一个四岁的孩子，正如你所料，四岁的孩子会玩，他们会发现它能做的所有事情。但当实验者改变了他们说的话——“这是我的玩具，我来向你展示它是怎么玩的”——并且做了一件事，比如捏响发声器。孩子们探索的可能性就会小得多。他们所做的，某种程度上很理性地，就是捏响发声器，照着成年人已经演示和
This is work that was done by Elizabeth Bonowitz and Laura Schultz and what they did was they showed the children this complicated thing that could do lots of different things. It could squeak, had a mirror, it had a light. And the question was, would the children discover all the things that the toy could do? And what they found was that if you give a complicated toy like that to a four-year-old, as you might expect, that four-year-olds play, and they find all the things that it could do. But when the experimenter just changed what they said, this is my toy, I'm going to show you how it works, and did one thing like squeak the squeaker. The children were much less likely to explore. What they did, sort of rationally, was squeak the squeaker, did what the adult had demonstrated
向他们建议的那样去做。我们有许多类似的结果，孩子们对某人正在进行教学、某人正在扮演老师的极其微弱的暗示非常非常敏感，这有一些优势，它缩小了他们将要考虑的选择范围。但就他们愿意考虑的探索范围而言，它也可能带来劣势。当然，游戏本身也可以是一种学习形式，思考游戏重要性的一种方法是考虑人工智能以及游戏如何塑造我们训练机器人的方式。
and suggested to them. And we have a number of different results that are like this where children are very, very sensitive to quite subtle indicators that someone's being pedagogical, that someone's being a teacher, and that has some advantages, that narrows down the number of options they're going to consider. But it can also have disadvantages in terms of the range of exploration that they're willing to consider too. Now of course play itself can be a form of learning and one way to think about the importance of play is to think about artificial intelligence and how play informs the way we train robots.
你在书中讨论了这个想法：研究人员如何利用游戏来帮助机器人学习，这又能告诉我们关于养育孩子的科学什么呢？嗯，事实证明，让机器学习的一个非常好的方法是给它一个早期的阶段，在这个阶段它只需玩耍，它可以尝试许许多多不同的选项，并获得大量关于系统如何运作的信息。例如，他们设计了一个机器人，它有一个早期的阶段，可以以这种奇怪有趣的方式到处跳舞
You talk about this idea in the book, how our researchers using play to help robots learn and what does that tell us then about the science of raising kids? Well it turns out that a very good way of getting a machine system to learn is to give it an early period where it can just play, it can just try out lots and lots of different options and get a lot of information about how the system works. So for example, they designed a robot that had a period early on where it could just kind of dance around in this kind of weird funny way
而实际上并不试图做任何特定的事情。事实证明，如果你给机器人一个到处跳舞的机会，弄清楚它的四肢能做什么，然后给它一个具体的工作，比如“去把这块布捡起来”，如果这个机器人有机会玩耍，它就会更有韧性。这是关于游戏的有趣之处之一。我认为每个人都有这样一种直觉，即游戏是重要且有价值的。但是，当然，如果你真的想要一个特定的结果，比如测试中的特定分数，如果你不玩耍，如果你只有非常具体的指导，你总是会做得更好。但如果你希望这种知识具有韧性，如果你希望某人能够灵活应变，说：“好吧，我没有学过如何做这个特定的事情，但我现在可以把我所做的事应用到别的事情上吗？”那么游戏似乎真的扮演了深层的角色。例如，对于机器人来说，那些玩过游戏的机器人，你可以取下它们的
without actually trying to do anything in particular. And it turns out that if you gave a robot a chance to just dance around, figure out what its limbs could do, and then you gave it a specific job like, you know, go and pick up this piece of cloth, the robot was more resilient if it had a chance to play. And this is one of the interesting things about play. I think everyone has the kind of the intuition that play is important and valuable. But of course, if you actually want to have a specific outcome, like a particular score
一只手臂，或者把它们推倒，它们仍然能够弄清楚如何够到那块布。对于那些只接受过该特定动作训练的机器人来说，情况并非如此。我认为这是游戏总体上能够发挥作用的一个很好的模型。所以你曾经和你的孙子奥吉（Ogie）在厨房里，你正在为煎饼打发蛋白，我明白你的孙子在模仿你，但并没有完全按照你的方式去做。告诉我发生了什么。生活中的一大乐趣是和两三岁的孩子一起烹饪，他们喜欢烹饪，
on a test, you're always going to do better if you don't play, if you just have very specific instruction. But if you want that knowledge to be resilient, if you want someone to be able to be flexible to say, okay, I didn't learn how to do this particular thing, but now can I apply what I did to something else, then play really seems to play a deep role. So for the robots, for example, the robots who had played, you could take off one of their
但当然，与此同时他们的效率极低。所以，你知道当奥吉在打发蛋白时，蛋白的泡沫最后溅得到处都是墙上，他这样做的方式远不如我自己动手那么有效率。但有趣的是，如果你跨文化观察，照顾者经常做的事情不是给孩子做什么的指示，而是让他们参与进来。所以让他们承担一部分工作，比如打发鸡蛋。艾莉森和我主要关注的是幼儿是如何学习的，所以我请她谈谈较大的孩子。她指出，虽然幼儿通过游戏和
arms or you could tip them over and they would still be able to figure out how to reach for the cloth. And that was not true for the robots who had just been trained on that particular action. And I think that's a good model for the things that play can do in general. So you were once in the kitchen with your grandson Ogie and you were whipping egg whites for pancakes and I understand your grandson was imitating you but not quite doing it the way you were doing it. Tell me what happened. One of the great joys of life is cooking with two and three worlds and they love to cook,
探索来学习得很好，但较大的孩子通过学徒制学习效果最好。他们模仿、练习、接受批评。但大多数学校的教学方式截然不同。艾莉森给我出了一个思想实验。所以想象一下，如果我们教棒球的方式就像我们目前教科学的方式一样。我们要做的就是让孩子们阅读关于棒球规则的书籍。当他们上高中时，我们会让他们重现
but of course they're extremely inefficient at the same time. So, you know, when Oggie's whipping egg whites, the egg whites end up having egg white fresco all over the walls and he's doing it in a way that is not nearly as efficient as it would be for me to do it myself. But it's interesting that if you look across cultures what caregivers often do is not give their child instructions on what to do but let them participate. So let them take on a piece like whipping the eggs. Allison and I had mostly focused on how young children learn, so I asked her to talk about older children. She said that whereas younger children learn well through play and
过去著名的棒球运动员。直到研究生院，他们才真正有机会玩这项运动。这几乎就是我们教科学的方式。直到研究生院，你才有机会真正去从事科学研究，而不是阅读科学或重构科学。特别是随着虚拟现实
exploration, older kids learn best through an apprenticeship. They imitate, they practice, they get critiques. But most schools teach in a very different way. Alison gave me a thought experiment. So imagine we taught baseball the same way that we teach science currently. What we would do is we would have children read books about baseball rules. When they got to high school, we would let them reproduce
和计算机环境等事物的发展，没有理由必须如此。孩子们实际上可以很早就开始进行探究、做实验和搞科学。我认为这对于写作之类的事情也是一样的。孩子们学习写作，但写作的方法是与一位优秀的编辑一起写作，看着一个称职的人写作。我认为我们的整个教育体系都可以更有效地朝着探索的方向发展，同时也朝着这种学徒制的方向发展。我在想，园丁模型和木匠模型之间的某些紧张关系是否归结为社会要求年轻人去做的事情不同。
famous baseball players of the past. And it wouldn't be till graduate school that they would actually ever get to play the game. And that's pretty much the way that we teach science. It's not till graduate school that you actually ever get a chance to do science as opposed to reading about science or reconstructing science. And especially with things like virtual reality
所以过去曾经有一个时期，我们需要大量的人加入工业劳动力队伍。但越来越多的人认为，我们期待年轻人去做的那类事情是更高阶的技能。我想平均主义的未来学家会告诉你，在20或30年内，大学教育可能行不通了，因为从大学毕业的人所能做的那些技能，可能会被机器人取代。所以在那个时候，你真的需要具备更高更高技能水平的人。我在想，这是否部分是园丁模型和木匠模型之间的紧张关系，因为如果你实际上需要的人不仅仅是理解（你知道）如何在工厂里做一堆事情，而是去理解更高阶的事情，那么
and computer environments, there's no reason for that to be true. Children could be actually doing inquiry and doing experiments and doing science early on. And I think the same thing's true for things like writing, for example. Children learn about writing, but the way to write is to write with a good editor to watch someone who is competent writing. I think our whole educational system could be oriented towards both exploration, but also this kind of apprenticeship system much more effectively. I'm wondering if some of the tension between the Gardner and the Carpenter model comes down to the different things that societies have called on young people to do.
这就需要达到一定水平的专业化和长期的训练，而不仅仅是通过探索和游戏就能获得的。它实际上必须通过某种系统和刻苦的训练，或者通过非常非常长的时间来获得。我们的社会正在发生的变化，是否是人们被木匠模型吸引的部分原因？嗯，我认为这就是人们脑海中的图景。但同样，科学告诉我们的却恰恰相反。
So there used to be a time when we needed large numbers of people to join the industrial workforce. But increasingly I think we are looking to young people to do the kinds of things that are much higher order skills. And I think the average futurist would tell you that in 20 or 30 years, a college education probably isn't going to cut it because the kinds of skills that someone who's graduated from college can do will probably be done by robots. And so at that point, you really need people who have much, much higher levels of skill. And I'm wondering if this is partly the tension between the Gardner and the Carpenter model, because if you actually need people who don't just simply understand, you know, how to, how to do a bunch of things in a factory, but to understand much higher order things, that
所以，如果你进行比较，即使从进化的角度来看，你把我们与我们最近的灵长类亲属进行比较，我们实际上通常不如其他生物那样擅长做专门的任务。我们非常擅长的是即兴发挥和寻找思考周围世界的新方法。这里有一个新问题。我不知道该怎么处理它。
requires a level of specialization and a length of training that is not just going to be acquired through exploration and play. It actually has to be acquired through sort of systematic and diligent training or a very, very long periods of time. Is it possible that the way our society is changing is part of the reason why people are drawn to the carpentry model? Well, I think that's the picture that people have. But again, what the science would tell us is just the opposite.
我会怎么做？这确实是我们未来需要的技能。而讽刺的是，这是一个新问题。我不知道该怎么处理它。我会怎么做？这确实是我们未来需要的技能。而讽刺的是，这是一种你无法通过仅仅试图学习该特定技能来学习的技能。这似乎是一种源于自由和探索感的技能，即使在其他领域也是如此。所以我认为我们可能会被诱导着去认为，如果我们希望儿童或成年人在这个极其不可预测、变化多端的世界中取得成功，我们需要做的是赋予他们越来越高水平的非常具体的学术技能。
So, if you compare, even from an evolutionary perspective, you compare us to our closest primate relatives, we're not actually as good at doing specialized tasks often as other creatures are. What we're very good at is improvising and finding new ways of thinking about the world around us. Here's a new problem. I don't know how to handle it.
我想，即使你走到离我在伯克利的所在地不远的硅谷，我想他们也懂。所以，你知道，谷歌大名鼎鼎地给员工放假一天去做任何他们想做的事。你知道，皮克斯（Pixar）的环境中也设有游戏屋。我认为这种趣味探索的价值是科技界的人所认同的。但我确实认为这与这种感觉存在冲突：即这一切太重要了。它必须被塑造，你想要一个特定的结果。所以讽刺的是，为了获得好的结果。
What would I do? That's really the skill that we're going to need in the future. And the irony is that that's a new problem. I don't know how to handle it. What would I do? That's really the skill that we're going to need in the future. And the irony is that that's a skill that you can't learn by just trying to learn that particular skill. That's a skill that seems to come from a sense of freedom and exploration even in other domains. So I think we may be kind of suckered into thinking, well, if we want children or adults to succeed in this very unpredictable, variable world, what we need to do is give them higher and higher and higher levels of very specific academic skills.
有时你不去刻意追求这些结果，反而会做得更好；讽刺的是，为了获得好的结果，有时你不去刻意追求这些结果，反而会做得更好，转而根本不去担心结果。我认为这是我在书中讨论的科学所带来的真正深刻的信息之一。艾莉森·高普尼克（Alison Gopnik）是加州大学伯克利分校的心理学和哲学教授。她是多本关于儿童发展书籍的作者，
And I think, you know, even if you go down to Silicon Valley near where I am at Berkeley, I think they get it. So, you know, famously, Google gives their employees a day off to do whatever they want. And, you know, Pixar has playhouses as part of their environment. I think the value of that kind of playful exploration is something that people say in the tech world get. But I do think it's intention with the sense that this is so important. It has to be shaped and you want a particular outcome. So the irony is to get to good outcomes.
她最近的一本著作是《园丁与木匠》（The Gardener and The Carpenter）。艾莉森，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。非常感谢你，尚卡尔（Shankar）。本周的节目由帕思·沙阿（Parth Shah）和雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）制作，塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、刘托马斯（Thomas Liu）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarell）和卡米拉·巴尔加斯·雷斯特雷波（Camila Vargas Chrestrepo）。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。
Sometimes you do better by not irony is to get to good outcomes, sometimes you do better by not trying specifically to get to those outcomes and instead not worrying about outcomes at all. And I think that's one of the real deep messages of the science that I'm talking about in the book. Alison Gopnik is a professor of psychology and philosophy at the University of California Berkeley. She's the author of several books about children's development,
我们下周见。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
and her most recent one is The Gardener and The Carpenter. Alison, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much, Shankar. This week's show was produced by Parth Shah and Raina Cohen, and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarell, and Camila Vargas Chrestrepo. I'm Shankar Vidantum.
她最近的一本著作是《园丁与木匠》。艾莉森，非常感谢你今天作客我们的“隐藏大脑”。非常感谢你，香卡。本周的节目由帕斯·沙阿和雷娜·科恩制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、托马斯·刘、劳拉·夸雷尔和卡米拉·瓦尔加斯·雷斯特雷波。我是香卡·维丹图姆。
See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下周见。本期节目尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。